how does the big answer we got change
the way we'll watch the new season of
yellow jackets we know they descend from
the ear to unimaginable things like
hunting the pit girl the interesting
question then is what strengths will
they discover in that process that might
be hard to let go of when they return to
civilization in 96 lottie's becoming a
comforting Force for the receptive
survivors she has a purpose in contrast
to at home where she's defined by her
mental illness seeing her as an adult
Translating that into Prosperity makes
you wonder about the survivors who might
have excelled at doing more Sinister
things that were also crucial for the
group's survival Misty is already gained
status because she was useful and lost
it because of the shrooms in the short
time they've been there there's a lot of
room for things like that to play out in
the 25 years in between and they can get
pretty dark if you use your imagination
what if you found your purpose had to
leave it behind and then pretend like it
never happened